[Música]
en Primera Plana
Carlos Serrano
[Música]
Bienvenidos en primera plano un programa
de radiofrance internacional y de France
24 esta semana ponemos el foco en la
crisis mundial del agua agudizada en los
últimos tiempos por sequías repentinas
nos acompañan en este estudio ya les
presento a nuestros invitados Joan
cortinas Muñoz es investigado en asuntos
de salud y acaba de publicar el libro el
campo de las políticas
hídricas investigación sobre la sequía
en el oeste de Estados Unidos bienvenido
Joan Hola Carlos qué tal Sebastián belú
es geógrafo profesor en el instituto de
altos estudios de América Latina y acaba
de publicar también lucha por el agua en
las Américas bienvenidos Sebastián
gracias Buenos días y Walter briston es
encargado de proyectos internacionales
en Brasil de Cáritas ecus católico
bienvenido Muchas gracias la crisis
mundial del agua agudizada por sequía
repentinas hoy nuestro asunto en Primera
Plana
lo advierten cada vez más estudios en el
mundo esta misma semana lo ha hecho la
revista Science el cambio climático
causado por la actividad humana ha
acelerado la frecuencia con que ocurren
sequías repentinas más difíciles de
prever Y ante las que es más complicado
adaptarse a partir de ahí los problemas
de agua comienzan a extenderse aquí en
Europa lo estamos viendo estos días con
varios ejemplos la sequía invernal da
paso aquí en Francia a un verano con
muchos temores episodios de graves
sequías también en el mcgrego ahora
mismo el agua como elemento de guerra
política en el parque de doñana en
España y si miramos al otro lado del
Atlántico pues qué decirles del Río
Colorado de los problemas de México y
Así podríamos establecer una lista sin
fin en estos momentos nuestros invitados
hoy nos van a hablar de ejemplos
diversos pero seguro que denominadores
comunes que podemos extraer para
entender estas sequías y sus derivados
como Las Guerras del agua cada vez más
frecuentes y las relaciones entre
factores naturales y sociales repasemos
algunas portadas de prensa diario La
macron presenta su plan de agua Saca los
remos en medio de un contexto de sequía
en Francia dice de garnian que la
demanda de agua fresca se incrementará
hasta un 40% en 2030 agudizando esta
crisis mundial
guardar agua es posible ahorrar dice la
publicación que también se multiplican
las iniciativas en este sentido tanto en
América como en Europa bueno Joan
sequías repentinas repentinas cada vez
más frecuentes lo estamos ya viendo cada
día un impacto lo vemos Ya casi en la
prensa día a día Qué características
tiene este fenómeno que ya está
impactando directamente nuestras vidas
Bueno pues lo que estamos viendo Es que
ha habido con el cambio climático
aumento las temperaturas cambio los
patrones de precipitaciones y con lo
cual está poniendo en jaque los
conocimientos que teníamos sobre los
recursos disponibles Esto está generando
sorpresas tenemos en países donde hay
abundancia de agua como Francia teníamos
medidas para saber cuál es el caudal de
un río Los acuíferos Pero estas medidas
como siempre digamos era más o menos
regulares teníamos dispositivos que se
muestren insuficientes en el en el
contexto actual entonces lo que está
pasando hoy en día y todo el mundo Lo
entenderá muy bien es un déficit
estructural entre la oferta y la demanda
es decir antes Teníamos dos botellas de
agua para ti para mí ahora tenemos una y
tenemos que beber igual pues lo que está
pasando es este déficit entre oferta y
demanda claro me imagino que hasta ahora
se consideraba sequia con un fenómeno a
largo plazo pero que ahora pueden
aparecer en pocas semanas y que son más
peligrosas por esta falta de adaptación
no exactamente la sequía no es solo
falta de precipitaciones las disonancias
entre factores naturales y sociales
siempre están en el corazón de Las
Guerras del agua sobre las que ha
escrito tanto Sebastián se ha venido
acentuando Sebastián estos conflictos
por el cambio climático
sí hay que ver que la sequía no es
solamente la falta de precipitaciones
hay también cambios en los patrones de
temperatura y sobre todo cambios en los
usos sea el uso urbano el uso de la
agricultura y los o Industrial el uso
para productos energética todo eso
influye para crear condiciones de sequía
tanto en Europa como en las Américas
Walter conoce la Brasil y nos va a
hablar de un proyecto muy interesante
en este contexto se trata del programa
un millón de cisternas que abarca un
área inmensa de hasta 10 estados
brasileños que es aproximadamente un
millón de kilómetros cuadrados no
corrígeme sí sí esto de este programa
nació de una iniciativa de la sociedad
civil y justamente Dónde está lo
interesante del programa que nos puede
hablar aquí a Francia es que son
soluciones descentralizadas llevadas a
cabo con la participación social con
control social también
puedes hablar claro
Sí entonces el programa un millón de
cister lo interesante es su nacimiento
porque viene justamente la experiencia
de un albañil que construyendo que salió
del norte de Brasil zona semiárida sale
a San Pablo a construir piscinas y dice
pero eso nos puede servir allá y junto a
un apoyo de organizaciones sociales de
base comenzó con cisternas con una
tecnología local adaptada y justamente
que busco llegar a cada población antes
El problema del agua de la sequía en
Brasil era tratado como un problema de
guerra contra la sequía combate lucha
contra la sequía sin embargo las
experiencias la sociedad civil han
enseñado que se trata de vivir con este
entorno social este entorno ambiental y
ahí la la experiencia la la cisternas de
la descentralización es que con
tecnologías de bajo recursos de bajo
costos llegó a tocar una población muy
amplia en que los beneficiarios mismos
participan de la construcción y
participan de la gestión de cómo no
dejar el agua un elemento centra en
donde los políticos se van a aprovechar
para con medidas clientelares llegas al
agua si me das tu foto entonces hay un
cambio de la relación También de la
población con el agua a partir de este
programa Bueno aquí en Europa preocupa
el verano
boreal tras haber pasado Ya una sequía
invernal macron presentaba Hace unos
días su plan de agua se habla de
restricciones departamentales Joan esto
obliga a replantearse varias cosas a
distintos niveles sobre la digamos la
política del agua el uso del agua la
agricultura Incluso el propio precio del
agua según sea para consumo o para uso
recreativos no Así es así es porque como
estamos en un proceso de cambio
climático y de cambio de disponibilidad
hídrica de manera indefinida es decir ya
no vamos a tener lo que teníamos hace
pocos años con lo cual se necesita
cambiar evidentemente la política de
agua porque se necesita cambiar los usos
como decía antes Sebastián Hay que usar
menos agua no tenemos otras otra
posibilidad porque no hay tanta agua
como vía por lo tanto hay que replantear
los usos agrícolas los usurbanos y los
usos industriales eso pasa por varios
canales que podemos si quieres entrar
luego y evidentemente el precio del agua
el precio del agua que pase el agua en
función de la oferta y la demanda tiene
un precio Pues con menos agua
forzosamente habrá que ver las políticas
tarifarias también y pero son temas
complejos y que podemos hablarlo después
Sebastián esto implica que lo que las
políticas del agua en general van a
ocupar cada vez una una importancia
mayor en las agendas de los gobiernos No
sí es probable y cuando uno mira el plan
de macron que acaba de mencionar uno se
da cuenta que hasta el momento Hay muy
poca política de restricción de usos por
una parte Francia tiene un modelo que es
el modelo modelo de las agencias de
Cuenca para gestionar el recurso y se da
cuenta que este modelo no es suficiente
para tomar la decisión que implica la el
aumento de la sequía Por una parte y por
otra parte lo que se va en el plan hay
muchas medidas que son solamente saber
más cuáles son o sea ni siquiera tenemos
los datos para medir de manera
satisfactoria Cuáles son los usos
Cuántas cuánto los agricultores está
tomando de las mapas freáticas entonces
hay que construir una política
totalmente nueva una nueva política del
agua Walter y a la vez yo creo que la la
política del agua no puede ser una
política aislada hay que tener cuidado
por ejemplo porque la política el
cuidado con los bosques del cuidado con
los océanos que son elementos
reguladores del clima y el clima hoy es
que nos está trayendo toda esa
problemática porque a la vez hay sequías
y es grave que en Francia para este
verano vamos a estar mal tal vez pero
sin embargo hay también los fenómenos de
inundaciones frecuentes y ya no tenemos
como la la rapidez de la frecuencia de
esos fenómenos nos llevan a tener que
buscar a la par de una política de agua
medidas más globales de enfrentamiento
del cambio climático con cambios de
modelo hablabas de la de la agricultura
efectivamente tenemos que Buscar Y eso
nos enseña la experiencia de Brasil
Buscar modelos adaptados culturas
adaptadas que no sean desperdiciosas que
desperdicien el agua que que consuman
demasiada agua que a la vez no va a ir a
la población de Brasil a Estados Unidos
un caso que yoan conoce bastante bien
porque es una sequía de 23 años en el
oeste del país que ha reducido
drásticamente el río Colorado que
proporciona agua potable y de riego para
Wyoming Colorado Yuta Nuevo México
Arizona Nevada según un pacto creo que
es de 1922 estas jurisdicciones reciban
asignaciones fijas de agua del río pero
ahora no hay suficiente para agua para
para proporcionársela hay aquí también
batalla política en la que amenaza
entrar el estado Federal no totalmente
es una batalla política esencial porque
el agua es esencial para la economía y
para la para la vida de estos siete
estados evidentemente Imagínate lo dices
tú 1922 el caudal del Río Colorado de
1922 Cien años después no tiene nada que
ver con sequía que ya no sequía sino que
es un déficit estructural es así lo que
está generando es que estos volúmenes
que se atribuyeron en 1922 siguen
estando vigentes Lo que pasa que no
existen tenemos volúmenes que por
derecho que tienen corresponden a los
estados pero no está está igual con lo
cual está generando una batalla el que
pasa el río Colorado de un río
Interestatal con lo cual es competencia
del presidente de Estados Unidos
Gobierno Federal y les ha dicho os
ponéis de acuerdo para ver cómo le
hacéis con el caudal disponible con los
volúmenes disponibles o yo voy a
intervenir y voy a Modificar el pacto de
1922 eso significa modificar totalmente
la estructura económica de varios
Estados Unidos con lo cual la batalla es
absolutamente política en el caso del
Colorado que
se consume en Estados Unidos no llega a
México Entonces digamos que río es un
río muerto cuando sale pasa la frontera
entre Estados Unidos y México
volvemos a encontrarnos este problema
que decía Sebastián de un factor natural
disponible y luego la una estructura
política y los conflictos sociales que
están alrededor de ese mismo factor que
usted ha retratado en muchísimos
conflictos en a lo largo de todas las
Américas No sí absolutamente o lo que
estamos viendo Hay muchísimas presiones
de uso y cada en los países digamos
están Buscando modelos para ajustarse A
cómo van vamos a regular digamos estas
demandas de agua y de los distintos
grupos sean agricultores grupos urbanos
grupos industriales y ahí yo creo que
hay que plantear el caso de Chile Chile
hace a principios ochenta toma una
reforma drástica del agua donde en la
práctica se privatiza el recurso Y eso
hace que el que paga más tiene acceso
Pero eso genera también con condiciones
extremas de sequía para grupos
marginales entonces crea más problema
para los grupos más vulnerables les
quiero preguntar porque hablamos de
ejemplos concretos hablamos de grandes
políticas pero también Tendremos que
hablar de la cultura del agua no porque
no sé si está extendida como sería
deseable la educación sobre el agua
necesitamos una mejor cultura del agua
en estos tiempos Walter por supuesto
pero la cultura del agua creo que ahí
ella puede inspirarse de ejemplos
concretos y comunitarios y partir de dos
cosas muy importantes en mi punto de
vista uno el agua como derecho
primeramente a partir de esta base el
agua es un derecho humano fundamental y
luego de eso pensar también algo como un
bien común como bien común tiene que
tener políticas de precio tiene que
tener políticas de acceso pensar Cómo
evitar los casos de privatización porque
la privatización que es un elemento
económico muy importante va a afectar
más fuertemente a las poblaciones
vulnerables Entonces cómo cuidar el agua
eso es algo que tiene que estar a la
base de toda política y de todo como
invitar al ciudadano a la ciudadana a
cuidarla a partir de esta visión de bien
común es de nosotros todos Entonces
tenemos que cuidar voy a retomar estos
elementos que está hablando de los que
está hablando Walter sobre la cultura
del agua de derecho y de bien común va a
ser a vuelta de pausa que en Primera
Plana hasta ahora
Enlace del cono Sur a Norteamérica de
los Andes a Centroamérica una cita
semanal con los temas más importantes de
los países del continente americano
presentada por los corresponsales de
France 24
enlace en France 24 y France 24.com
la historia de nuestro mundo está en
constante cambio el flujo de información
es cada vez mayor estamos ahí con todos
los temas nos comprometemos con la
verificación desde el terreno en todas
las circunstancias para anticipar el
futuro y entender el presente lo
acompañamos 24 horas 7 días a la semana
France 24 una mirada diferente a la
actualidad libertad
seguimos en Primera Plana esta semana
hablando de la crisis mundial del agua a
partir de las sequías que estamos viendo
y que los múltiples episodios que vemos
en la prensa lo hacemos con Joan
cortinas Muñoz Sebastián velud geógrafo
y Walter briston encargado de proyectos
internacionales en Brasil de Cáritas
antes de la pausa Walter estaba poniendo
encima de la mesa dos elementos que hay
que considerar en la cultura del agua
una el derecho común y otra el bien
común a la hora de hablar de bien común
Walter se refería al precio al precio
del agua entienden Joan que el precio
por litro de agua no puede ser lineal es
decir que no puede costar lo mismo un
litro para beber un que un litro para
llenar una bañera por ejemplo es no sé
si el tema del precio del agua ha sido
hasta ahora como un tabú bueno depende
el país Qué pasa aquí en Francia Por
ejemplo si nos situamos en el contexto
de abundancia hasta hasta hace poco el
agua si uno pregunta un ciudadano
francés cuánto paga de agua la Gente ni
sabe cuánto sabe ni sabe cuánto paga de
agua Qué pasa es una es las
posibilidades para reducir el consumo
evidentemente Es fiscalizar los
volúmenes de agua los volúmenes
esenciales cuesta más baratos son gratis
Y a medida que aumentamos el consumo se
fiscaliza Y es más caro de manera
progresiva Es una posibilidad lo que
pasa Que eso genera varios problemas
todo es un poco complejo claro
por ejemplo en Francia las grandes
ciudades como en París no hay contadores
individuales de consumo de agua Qué pasa
para pasar una tonificación progresiva
habría que instalar no sé cuántos
millones de contadores de agua eso tiene
un coste muy importante que podría hacer
incrementar el precio del agua hay otra
otro efecto perverso que se podría
controlar pero hay que tenerlo en cuenta
es la salida del sistema fuera de las
grandes ciudades la gente puede utilizar
pozos pozos que de son ilegales etcétera
si uno aumenta la tarifa del agua hay
tendencia a tener más gente que va a
utilizar pozos ilegales con lo cual hay
que aumentar los controles aumentar los
controles son más agentes públicos Bueno
se puede Es una posibilidad pero hay que
estudiarla muy bien para ver cómo se
hace de manera efectiva sin que estos
efectos perversos
sean más negativos que positivos muy
interesante Ya ven que no es tan fácil
que también efectos perversos en
cualquier solución fácil que queramos
tener Sebastián Sí por ejemplo cuando
Walter habla del agua como un derecho
humano y Estamos de acuerdo con eso eso
llevó por ejemplo en Ciudad de Buenos
Aires en que no haya ningún tipo de
medición del agua entonces la persona
con una casa grande con un césped con
dos coches va a utilizar mucha agua para
todos este elemento de Confort digamos y
no va a pagar absolutamente nada es una
tarifa muy reducida Entonces como dice
Joan poner en marcha tarifas digamos
diferenciadas y si tú hablas de agua
toma para tomar y agua para la bañera
tendríamos que tener un medidor en la
cocina y otro en el baño y eso es muy
difícil pensarlo Entonces no no todo se
puede solucionar a partir de este cambio
tarifario Si hay modelos por ejemplo
puede tener tarifa baja para los
primeros metros cúbicos y luego pagas
más para los metros cúbicos que que
siguen Pero hay mismo con eso que te dé
medidores tienes que tener controles y
tienes que tener que la gente acepte
pagar para el agua por eso también hubo
guerras del agua porque la gente no
quería pagar en cualquier caso la
realidad que estamos viviendo nos lleva
al menos a explorar de lo que de lo que
están hablando Es decir al menos a
explorarlo y a tenerlo en cuenta cosa
que hace unos años ni siquiera lo
teníamos en cuenta justamente pero ahí
es donde el riesgo también está en
adoptar el agua ver al agua como una
mercancía Y eso al adoptarla pensarla
como derecho humano no es la cuestión de
no pedir para pagar pero sí de adoptar
políticas adaptadas Entonces es un bien
común Hay que cuidarlo hay que en eso
por eso entiendo cultura del agua como
como llevar las personas a cuidar de eso
que es de todos no les pregunto la de la
desalación es una buena opción hasta que
punto las centrales de este uso pueden
paliar el déficit Joan Bueno como todo
es complejo es decir puede ser hay
muchas alternativas o posibilidades y
hay que adoptarlas muchas al mismo
tiempo pero eso es el corto plazo es
decir las desalinización es una medida a
corto plazo en la urgencia a largo plazo
el informe del gobierno francés nos dice
que hay que cambiar esencialmente de
modelo agrícola es principal pasar del
modelo Industrial agroecología reducir
los usos etcétera bueno en Casos de
emergencia se puede utilizar la
visualización porque no pero hay efectos
perversos que hay que ver cómo se
solucionan Cuáles son
es agua más cara uno pero no solo eso él
tiene consecuencias medioambientales
porque se genera lo que se llama la
salmuera es decir la concentraciones de
sal mucho más elevadas en el proceso de
sanación que genera efectos negativos
sobre los ecosistemas marinos se generan
tóxicos en el proceso de instalación se
aumenta el precio del agua se utiliza
electricidad mucho más electricidad con
lo cual hay que alimentar se aumenta el
consumo y electricidad con lo cual
energía nuclear hay toda una serie de
efectos que siempre hay que ver con lo
cual lo que quiero decir en general con
las soluciones técnicas cualquiera que
ellas sean no pueden ser la solución la
solución es son un cambio de modelo
general en el del agua punto el resto
son soluciones técnicas puntuales Walter
en el caso de Brasil usted ha conocido
el desarrollo de tecnologías a bajo
coste con participación social no
exactamente ahí Creo que hay varios
temas igual no hemos todavía tocado pero
la la el saneamiento hay que cuidar a
ese entre las tecnologías hay una
interesante que si se aplica en modelos
agrícolas de Cómo reutilizar el agua
justamente para cierto tipo de uso
Porque además del precio También tenemos
algunas situaciones absurdas Que es que
en Francia el agua potable lo estamos
utilizando pero para todo entonces cómo
tendríamos que adaptar también los usos
la recuperación de agua de lluvia
Incluso en Francia creo que es posible
que hacerlo y para eso podemos
inspirarnos justamente de esas
tecnologías sociales de bajo costo donde
hay la creatividad de la población y en
medio campesino es muy fuerte en América
Latina Sebastián y toda usted a
cartografiado todas las luchas por el
agua o varias en las Américas qué
lecciones puede podemos sacar de esas
guerras del agua que usted conoce bien
en las Américas qué lecciones podemos
aplicar a esta actualidad que nos brinda
con tantos episodios de sequía primero
que la solución es tecnológicas no son
nunca soluciones sino hay soluciones
políticas y social que las acompaña O
sea la solución tecnológica en sí no
sirve o sea hay que ponerla en contexto
y dos diría que si bien son importantes
iniciativas locales iniciativas
regionales creo que también muy
importante tener Marcos regulatorios
nacionales que el estado sea garante
digamos de la buena del buen uso de la
gestión y que para que estos mecanismos
funcionen porque hay que pensar también
que si bien hay usos individuales o en
los hogares del agua hay también muchos
usos que son usos masivos que son
industriales o para la producción de
energía por eso cuando hablamos de
cultura del agua y estamos todos de
acuerdo que Hay que cuidarla que mejor
no agregar jardín con agua potable Bueno
hay una serie de cosas pero también hay
que pensar que cuando utilizamos
electricidad estamos utilizando agua
porque las centrales térmicas requieren
de mucha agua entonces hay unas cadenas
digamos de uso que hay que mapear con
mucha mucho detalle para entender bien
Dónde están los problemas soluciones
políticas
estado garante un marco regulatorio nos
está apuntando Sebastián Esto me llega a
pensar que se necesitan mayores
compromisos a todos los niveles de la
administración del político del de los
consumidores del de la educación es
decir detrás de todo ello está la
palabra compromiso a todos los niveles
Empezando por el político no Joan
absolutamente es decir en el que retomo
el caso del Colorado Qué pasa cuando el
presidente de Estados Unidos habla con
los Estados federados los siete estados
Qué pasa se está moviendo en el oeste
estadounidense estamos llegando a
cambios en la gestión del agua pero esos
cambios vienen por la determinación del
secretario interior que les dijo o
reducir el consumo de 20% o voy a
alterar los contratos que tenéis
Colorado eso esa determinación político
ha sido esencial para ver un cambio de
los niveles inferiores de gobierno aquí
en Francia yo creo que hay que tener en
cuenta una cosa estamos en un cambio de
pantalla ya todo el mundo ya tiene casi
el gobierno francés dice que hay que
reducir de 25% y ya no estamos en la
discusión de no no sea un se puede hacer
soluciones tecnológicas el problema es
la determinación y Hoy estamos aún un
poco timoratos que dice macron dice
Bueno vamos a ver si los usuarios ya con
buena voluntad reducen sus usos sobre
todo los agrícolas no en Estados Unidos
ha cambiado porque no no es una voluntad
no son las voluntades de los
agricultores el presidente les dijo
reducís o cambio el sistema entonces
redujeron pues esa determinación
política es muy necesaria y no es un
compromiso de ciudadanos es ante todo
Una determinación de los poderes
políticos no está de acuerdo Walter que
por mucho que Confiemos en la tecnología
y pueda ayudarnos mucho la voluntad y el
compromiso político al final es
determinante en estos casos que estamos
hablando hoy por supuesto por supuesto
incluso y el ejemplo de Brasil también
puede hablar mucho de eso
es política decir a dónde va cómo va a
tratar el recurso del agua como una
mercancía como bien de acaparamiento
como
bien para para algunos pocos no entonces
la política la primera en el estado de
decir a quién va a la prioridad y los
cambios Estoy totalmente de acuerdo con
los regulatorios yo creo que las dos
dimensiones se completan y ahí la en
Brasil Durante los últimos cuatro años
todo este programa de participación
social política pública con con la
inclusión de la sociedad civil fueron
abandonados el programa un millón de
cisternas que hablábamos quedó
completamente abandonado cero
presupuesto se va a retomar ahora
entonces justamente por qué retomarlo
Porque sí
mostró que puede a presentar respuestas
a la población en un contexto de sequía
recurrente como es el contexto seminario
de Brasil Sebastián quieres Añadir algo
más Sí me parece que en estos temas es
importante regulatorio y es importante
investigar mucho más sobre cómo se
utilizan las aguas O sea hay un también
una falta de conocimiento que esforcé
mucho para conocer mejor estos
ecosistemas hidrosistema o hidrosoos
sistemas donde se combina sociedad y
agua
Cómo se elaboran cómo se deberían
elaborar estoy pensando que al hablar de
un marco regulatorio Esto me lleva a
pensar que hay que pensar Cómo se
elaboran los planes de suministro entre
agricultura y consumo humano que También
incluye usos industriales y turísticos
es decir que cada vez vamos a tener que
elaborar con más ojo o fiscalizar mejor
estos como se elabora en este tipo de
planes a partir de las administraciones
políticas Joan sí está claro y Sebastián
lo acaba de mencionar tenemos una una
falta de conocimiento y pasaba también
en los de Estados Unidos pero pasa en
Francia pasa en España no sabemos
exactamente como se utiliza el agua no
Por qué Porque hasta el momento no nos
hemos dado las herramientas para hacerlo
eso es importantísimo Me acuerdo cuando
hablaban en Estados Unidos con
responsable de medio ambiente me decía
es que el problema no es solo El Marco
regulatorio es que para que podamos
regular tenemos que saber cómo se
utiliza y no lo sabemos lo único que
tenemos es que los agricultores nos
envían una vez al año el uso que ellos
dicen que hacen del agua con lo cual es
tan impreciso que no podemos saber
Entonces evidentemente los datos y el
conocimiento es muy importante Cómo se
realizan esto estos Cómo se reparten
depende el país en Francia los comités
de Cuenca es el parlamento del agua
donde los usuarios se ponen de acuerdo
para tener un tipo de Para repartir el
agua y está enmarcado como decía antes
la pantalla la hemos pasado en Europa
tenemos una directiva marco del agua del
2000 que regula muy bien el agua dice
cómo hay que utilizarla y que hay que
respetar los ecosistemas los usos
industriales domésticos y agrícolas Lo
que pasa que los comités de Cuenca no es
que el marco regulatorio no exista es
que los agricultores tienen mucho más
poder que los otros usuarios con lo cual
ganan la batalla en el parlamento del
agua pues hay que equilibrar poderes en
los dispositivos que existen Para
repartir el helado muy interesante
Walter algún apunte más no yo pensaba
hablan de los agricultores
agricultores y agricultores no Qué tipo
de agricultura justamente tú hablabas de
la agroecología y una agricultura
Industrial Hoy está presentando sus
límites en relación a la gestión del
agua no hablamos del tema para hay
muchos pero el tema de los residuos de
pesticidas en en el agua de consumo
humano que estamos viviendo también aquí
en Francia entonces todo eso interroga
el modelo de agricultura el modelo
alimentario el modelo
de gestión del agua que tenemos que
adoptar pues muy interesante lo que me
han contado me quedo sin tiempo para más
pero desde luego ha sido un programa
interesantísimo hablar de una realidad
que ya tenemos encima de la mesa porque
el cambio climático esas cosas que nos
defiende las consecuencias del cambio
climático ya no son el futuro ya son el
presente y las estamos sufriendo día a
día y si no cojan cualquier periódico y
lo van a ver Muchísimas gracias a los
tres y a todos ustedes hasta la próxima
semana quien en Primera Plana gracias
[Música]